Donald Trump did one of his bill signing
ceremonies in New York earlier this week
and it was this huge huge massive
defense policy bill seven hundred and
sixteen billion dollars in total and
this defense bill which Congress passed
includes some provisions related to
Russia so for example in this
congressionally passed and Trump signed
bill Trump is forbidden from using
federal money to recognize Russian
control of Crimea Trump is banned from
putting forward military cooperation
with Russia until Russia leaves Crimea
Trump must report to Congress what he's
done to address Russian violations of
the Open Skies treaties there's a tour
so Russia related provisions and Trump
signed it into law and then just hours
after signing it he puts out a written
statement saying he disagrees with 52 of
the provisions in the law which he just
signed as well as disagreeing with four
of the eight provisions that deal with
Russia and that he might just go ahead
and ignore those because as the written
statement says Trump feels that some of
those provisions undermine the
president's quote role as the sole
representative of the nation in foreign
affairs this is genius that this is a
brilliant way to get it both ways on the
Russia stuff he signs it into law right
so he can't out I'm tough on Russia and
Trump askance a look trump signed this
thing into law and it has eight
provisions that are tough on Russia but
then on the back end he puts out a
statement saying well half of those
things about Russia I signed into law
I don't believe are good things I don't
even know that the government that that
Congress has the ability to control my
ability as the sole representative on
foreign policy for the country and is
signaling that he's just going to go
forward and ignore them and we know why
Trump doesn't like those provisions
related to Russia Trump wants to
coordinate and cooperate militarily with
Russia on what who knows but he just
loves that alpha blad Amir Putin and he
wants to do big boy military stuff with
Vladimir Putin Trump has no interest in
pursuing Vladimir Putin or his takeover
of
amia which is again why Trump is saying
some of these things I don't know that I
really like this is more of the same and
it does matter okay this isn't the
distraction this is what Trump wants to
distract from right so like NFL players
kneeling that is a distraction it's not
a fake issue but it's a distraction when
you see what's going on geopolitically
with Trump the Omarosa n-word tapes it
does matter if the president is
haphazardly referring to black people
with the n-word of course it matters
but this is the the meat of it this is
what's going on when Trump talks about
the Omarosa dog vile dog thing or
lowlife dog when Trump talks about the
anthem whatever this is the stuff that
Trump doesn't want you paying attention
to and just look at the statement from
Russia that came out after the Helsinki
summit they put this out recently the
Kremlin saying quote Russian officials
were pleased with the Helsinki summit
between presidents Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin US and Western
intelligence agencies have found but
Moscow is perplexed that Trump is not
delivering more Russia friendly policies
in its aftermath
why isn't Trump doing more Russia
friendly stuff we'll hear some saying
that four of these eight provisions he
doesn't like I hope Pat that when
history looks back at this they are able
to accurately encapsulate the scope of
the absurdity of what we're experiencing
well we certainly can't do that now and
now conventional wisdom would tell you
that you can't have it both ways
that you can't have your cake and eat it
too but because our media is so
polarized and because you know just the
issue of whether the Robert Miller
investigation should continue is so
polarizing and people are on one side or
another it allow it can exist still
which can the the what can exist exactly
just the the away be able to sign the Oh
to get it both ways all right yeah yeah
most people will not realize that Trump
both signed it into law and is against
those provisions right you will either
here
Trump signed these very very tough
provisions against against Russia in
into law and they will say see that's
evidence that he's not compromised that
he is tough on Russia or they'll hear
the headline that hey look Trump is
saying he doesn't like these anti
tough on Russia provisions that he
signed into law the idea that
everybody's gonna have both sides of the
story it's not gonna happen in today's
media environment and we got to pay
attention to this because he benefits
every time he takes six positions on the
same issue and sites whichever one is
convenient depending on who he's talking
to
everybody loses with that the trumpets
think that they're winning because it's
their guy but everybody actually loses
when the president is allowed to
obfuscate in that way